welcome to another episode of not too
deep with me grace Helbig your host
today is thrilling exciting even we have
Janet Varney with us today she is a
comedian and amazing voice-over actress
an amazing actress to start SF
Sketchfest she's the voice of Cora in
Legend of Korra she's just she's got
rooked fortune rookie that write fortune
cookie sorry guys she's just done so
much that it's really intensely hard to
keep up with and get ready to learn so
much more about the life of Janet Varney
on this episode of not too deep I am in
love with this woman and I know you will
be too this episode of not too deep is
brought to you by our good buddies at
Squarespace who wants you to know you
can turn your great idea into a reality
with Squarespace
Squarespace makes it easier than ever to
launch your passion project whether
you're showcasing your work or selling
products of any kind with beautiful
templates and the ability to customize
just about anything you can easily make
a beautiful website yourself and if you
do get stuck Squarespace is 24/7
award-winning customer support is there
to help so head to squarespace.com slash
grace for your free trial and when
you're ready to launch use the offer
code grace to save 10% off your first
purchase of a website or domain thank
you so much for being here thanks for
having me I am so excited because you
wear 12 thousand hats it's nuts but if I
really did have just like I would be so
impressed amazing to me okay how do you
let's say someone walks up to you they
know nothing about you they're an alien
let's say I don't want to play this out
you just want to say this is a
hypothetical you'd want to pretend to be
the person who walks up to you off the
street how do you describe because I
always have a hard time describing like
what I do I bet yeah you and I have the
same yeah how would you describe what
you do to someone to be honest with you
grace that is an uncomfortable question
for me to be asked and I feel like the
number one thing I fall back on and I am
absolutely not proud of this is this
kind of apology really it's an immediate
apologetic response where because you
don't have one
yes and I feel like like it's the it's
the the immediate face I think I might
assume is one of like no boy I'm so
sorry that you asked that how do I
answer it and then what ends up
happening is because this happened
fairly recently I sound like I'm
embarrassed of anything that like
whatever my responses I sound like I'm
like just bloom which is not true right
and I don't know if that's like I mean I
think that's something that a lot of
people do if they don't want to come off
as you know I say that I think it's you
know maybe a little more female than
male in terms of how we've been
socialized yeah you know but yeah
there's this sort of sense of like no no
I do this thing and then I have this you
know and produce a festival but I also
mumble and then it just sounds again
like I'm ashamed just going like I mean
I'm really lucky I get to do a bunch of
stuff you know yeah I I get to do stuff
you know I get to be on camera and write
and do stuff in LA and then I also have
this festival I'm really proud like I
should just sort of figure out a way to
do it that's compartmentalized and also
not apologetic but I also I relate to
that
extremely yes a very weird thing and
then you feel bad that you seem
apologetic to this person that's
genuinely as many layers there are hats
for you and me yeah well so you did The
Legend of Korra which is obviously like
a huge in like the fan base for that
must have been so overwhelming to come
to terms with when you first started
doing it yeah it definitely was I mean
it was a it was it was an amazing sort
of getting dropped into the center of
something that was pre established right
so the first series which was so great
so it was very scary and it was a relief
when the you know the response at least
the response that I was exposed to is
positive the pressure of that must be
insane that you go in and you're like I
just want to do a good job and there are
people that you know love you know these
creative enterprises so much that you're
like I don't want to disappoint these
people so and I saw that you just went
to New York comic-con did but you went
there for your IFC series
yes okay yeah but you've been there
before yes before let me Sakura yeah
yeah I've gone for Legend of Korra
yeah those might be like my seventh New
York comic-con really probably I think
many San Diego uh slightly less because
there was a yeast two years I couldn't
go but those are but I never went as as
just an attendee like people that you
know I had friends who were on shows and
stuff and would go down there and then
friends who would go down there as as
fans and I was incredibly intimidated by
the idea of going to a con I'm not it's
over you know I don't think you based on
what I know about you I seriously doubt
that you or I are the people who feel
comfortable in a crowd which is true of
many people who go to Comic Cons
absolutely they overcome that with
enthusiasm
yes with the graciousness of enthusiasm
and excitedness said but I yes I do not
like crowd situations at all however I
fundamentally understand like the pure
joy that this situation brings to so
many other people and so it's like
rationalizing in your head like your own
discomfort for the comfort of other
people yeah do you have now that you're
kind of like a veteran at Comic Cons and
cons in general do you have like your
go-to list of things you do or ways you
prep before you go that's a good
question um mm I wouldn't say there's
much I do to prep other than you're just
your general packing yeah but I do feel
like I kind of you know sort of
understand about myself like what my
what my limits are you know I I've
learned very quickly that if I go out
after a day at a con I will probably
have lost my voice by the next day yeah
and that's an important yeah so there's
a there's a sort of like hibernation
that happens the second my whatever is
being asked of me is complete yeah I'm
not I don't then say like oh you know
because there's a lot of the time there
are people in town that perhaps you even
live in the same city regularly but you
just never see them right when you're in
this kind of specific situation there is
a different opportunity presented to
hang out yeah and I
I've come to understand that that isn't
probably helping anyone if phil lamarr
is in town let's go have dinner and then
maybe we'll go to a bar and we'll just
talk and we'll scream and run scream
over some stuff that probably doesn't
need to be screamed about and yeah so
that's that's very true yeah cool like
okay I'll see everyone tomorrow I'll be
in the room
has anyone ever recognized you just
based on your voice yes two times that I
can have two times that I can think of I
had people who weren't looking at me
who sort of looked up with like yes an
expression and then kind of never asked
or they didn't work but yeah once was I
was getting rung up at a Whole Foods go
and she was like you know busy bringing
everything up but she was very nice and
making conversation a certain point
somehow she just like a light bulb went
on she looked up and she was like
something stupid like you know iceberg
lettuce not a lot of nutrients in it
like I'm sure with some really stupid
just menial you know and then the other
time and I do remember because it is so
rare I was at I was at the Walt Disney I
was at the I was at the Music Hall right
why am i blanking on what it's called
but the the Walt Disney Hall though one
that's downtown
okay and and I was at like a Christmas
concert I think you can go and do like I
called the holiday sing-along okay and
two girls who were sitting right in
front of me I was just having a
conversation with the person I was with
and then all of a sudden and they were
like engaged in a lot of fervent
whispering and I didn't have any sense
of that it was about me and then they
both turned around into each other so I
was like they're like are you Janet
Varney from The Legend of Korra so they
had only heard my voice and were like
debating I don't know but those were
those were you know that's very cool
right those are both surprising to me
that's so cool I'd also like must be
strange and fun to have those kind of
experiences it was totally cool and I
was and usually my response when we
people say like oh what's so weird to
you you know your voice sounds like
Korra I'm always like oh yeah I borrow
her voice like that's
you know it's her voice I just use it
when she's not doing stuff
I hope what's they like a primary demo
or what was the demo for that show like
was male/female like young old oh yeah I
mean I think it was I think Nickelodeon
presented it as kids above the age of
probably 12 or something but then what
ends up being true is is that it
attracts people of all ages I mean when
I do signings and stuff it's it's
amazing to me how diverse the group is
and I would say it's like equal guys and
girls yeah because you guys tackle real
like world issues yeah it gets dark yeah
really they don't pull any punches on
the show but that must be cool to be
part of something that has like such a
global kind of like impact it's cool
yeah it's it was Vince nothing but it's
just a complete honor yeah okay I want
to talk about fortune cookie great news
I love tarot cards I love tarot card
readers I get I overdue for getting my
whole cards read how did this come about
because you created this and now it's on
IFC
people can watch the whole thing yeah
it's it's it's short form you can watch
it on IFC com you gets on YouTube I mean
there's a reason cameos from tons of
hilarious people it's so fun tone of it
is like weird and silly and like just
like it's a really kind of goofy
satirical humor that I really really
enjoy I mean so much to me thank you so
much so tell me all about this how did
this come to its creation well so my
actually my friend Grady Lyle who does a
bunch of voices on on cartoons and stuff
as well I I don't know that I've named
her specifically but I was just with her
at Comic Con and I was like maybe I
should just start acknowledging that she
was the person that she actually saw a
psychic and had an amazing experience
yeah and I have I had never gone to one
and and and kind of had the curiosity I
have that like I think this is very
normal uncommon especially for people
kind of in like a nerd or geek culture
where you sort of have maybe a wild
imagination and you have a lot of
optimism
maybe you also have a healthy dose of
cynicism and so there's this like push
and pull always I'm like I would love to
see you go straight I'm like it just is
not happening for me so I thought well
listen if ever there's a time to have
this you know to get a reading by
someone it's gotta be after this friend
of mine has had this extraordinary
experience where she can point to and
any number of things that she felt came
to fruition rather quickly
okay after she went so I went and saw
this person I did not have the same
experience women optimistically open my
eyes yes people don't have good
experiences because they don't go in
with an open mind yeah they go in with
pure citizen yes so at least you could
say you tried I did try and that there
and there was definitely there were a
couple of things that he hit on that
again I wish I could say I felt like
were based on a real psychic gift but
but but I was overwhelmed by this idea
of you know just even like somebody
who's not a real psychic if the such a
thing even exists again I'm ready he's
so excited but that you know he that
there were things that he could kind of
get to you know but with some work she
was sort of like I'm getting that and
you know you sort of start to kind of be
like yes I do need to let that person
out of my life you know you sort of so
it really did stick with me and and I
just became really fixated on this idea
of at some point getting to play you
know some sort of psychic be a real or
fake and so that was probably six or
seven years ago and it's kind of it's
kind of evolved first it was just like a
fictional character on a sitcom who you
know was raised by a con artist dad who
has kind of has to reckon with it was
very light it was just very this is sort
of very light okay and then it gradually
turned more and more into like maybe
it's just me is an alternate universe
version of me who is perhaps a little
more shallow and
you use everyone's real names there's
some people that are and some people
that's always weird when it's like you
know yeah but you have some people who
are pretty well known who are playing
not themselves and which is a strong way
to open well and there we sort of make
fun of that even like as I say your very
own brand for me because it's IFC and
IFC does Portlandia but yeah I'm really
bad at it essentially I think in the
second season will probably flashback to
what actually happens but this the idea
is that I'm just in a bath I just go
into a bathroom right we never seen
there's a person in there who is like
you know I'm a psychic and I'd love to
do your reading while you're sitting on
the toilet I don't even need to look at
you while I'm doing it I do it and this
person volunteers this this idea of like
oh you know you have the gift and I
absolutely my fictitional my fictitious
Janet definitely did not believe in
psychic powers in any way shape or form
up until someone told her she was
psychic and she's just self-important
enough that she's like I'm sure that's
true if any one psychic it probably is
me yeah and so she decides to sort of
give up on show business and and this is
a perfect excuse as to is to become you
know fortune teller and just has zero
knowledge and sort of you know part of
the arc of the show that actually is
kind of you know there are those moments
where it's like oh this is wait now that
I'm weak of writing something that's now
getting a little uncomfortable close to
the truth it's the sort of idea of if
you don't fully commit to anything right
even just like the apology version of me
who's like no I do all these different
things then it doesn't hurt as much yeah
it doesn't work so there is that kind of
underlying thread of truth which is like
if you don't make a commitment to really
try to see how to be something you won't
be hurt but you also don't really know
what your full potential is that's super
cool so this must be kind of cathartic
and therapeutic in a way for you and
also just like totally creative at the
same time I think it really is because
that's part of you know part of the
reason that I think I really took so
long you know when you're in comedy and
when you create your own whatever
version of your own projects you bring
to the table there's always people
saying you should do stand-up or you
should do this or way writing a project
for yourself and I think I got so
wrapped up and doing other people's
shows or doing improv which requires
zero writing pray that that I hadn't
ever buckled down and said let's just
make it let's just make something so it
was cathartic and again it sort of like
has a weird reflection on kind of what
goes on in the show and then it was just
such a joyful process to know that's
great call friends and go hey I thought
you would think it was fun to play you
know your vert the version of yourself
who's this or you know do you want to
play a character who starts a cult like
is that funny to you and then you know
and then just kind of go from there
that's so fun yeah it doesn't become
work that it's just literally just
getting to hang out and have imagination
with your friends it's so it was really
fun and it was really fun writing for
people knowing you know the difference
between writing for a part that hasn't
yet been cast and writing for you know a
James Roday yeah you I just had him in
my head all the whole time but then when
he came and we read a scene together you
know the first day we were shooting
together I was so giddy just hearing it
because it's always gonna be a little
different and better and he came up with
some great improvise style that was just
made it so alive and I I was hi thank
you I'm so lucky you know that's awesome
so have you guys started season two no
no no because this just came out like a
week ago but are there do we have ideas
for season two was he is for like eight
season okay great I mean it could be a
full you know it could be a half-hour
show yeah that has like 12 episodes a
season love that did you hear that
everyone
yeah specifically people with money and
who make choices IFC so you have like
this really insane comedy background and
you started San Francisco Sketchfest
yes and that's how long has that been
going for we are going to have our 18th
all this January that is bonkers that's
nuts to me it's like I can't even throw
my own birthday party let alone like I
can't even throw my own birthday party
if I didn't have two partners my
partner's David Owen Cole Stratton who I
met at San Francisco State when I was
there and we were students they are like
there's no way that if both of them
walked away tomorrow I could ever do it
and it's not just because it's too much
work for one person it's because they
they're my family and then you know
they're like brothers and and they you
know push me forward and inspire me and
challenge me and and I think they feel
the same about me so 18 years I know
it's crazy at a certain point it just
becomes like do it I guess you know so
how is it grown in the 18 years I mean
I'm sure like the first year is
literally like you're like we're trying
something absolutely 100% yeah the first
year we did it we would only did it
because we were in a sketch troupe and
had nowhere really to perform because
San Francisco has a great comedy history
but it just didn't have a lot of places
to try sketch sure like honestly one of
the main places that people did it there
was a huge column in the middle of the
room amount of people but you know 10 of
those people would not have an eyeline
it was rough so we ended up just asking
five other sketch groups that we had met
with in that kind of small community is
you know I want to say it might have
been the only sketch groups in the city
besides us but actually but it's a small
city so actually it's kind of cool that
there were six you know that we're all
out doing their own thing and we just
said you know we we think you're maybe
having the same hard time we are what if
we all group together and we just
present this as a sketch comedy festival
there's strength in numbers we can you
know we'll split the cost of the theater
rental for a month and and we our group
will sort of take on the you know
publicity and let's get the word out and
we'll manage selling tickets and we can
all sort of co-headline with each other
in the various combinations so we can
also expose we'll have a chance to
you'll have a chance to be exposed to
all other five audiences and fans that's
awesome yeah and
so we got a ton of coverage from the
press which was really I think what made
it you know work the first year and it
worked well enough that the next year we
got us you know 200 seat theater instead
of at a 90 seat theater and and started
inviting people from out of town that's
cool so how many on average sketch teams
are there each year now
they went from six to yeah well and now
it's a it's just the Sanford's its SF
Sketchfest because that's what we named
ourselves from the beginning but it's
been more than sketch comedy for I mean
maybe the like 15 of the 18 years has
been more than sketch
we've probably even had improv the
second year but and music so now it's
like you know there's probably like 60
sketch groups that perform or a
combination maybe of 60 improv and
sketch groups that are up and coming
that's a total guesstimate but it's a
lot yeah then we have yeah then we have
like you know film panels and reunions
and we do big tributes to our heroes and
you know music shows and just every form
of comedy you can imagine we've explored
even up to like a show where people give
humorous tours through a museum you know
it's just sort of everything I want to
get into the weird side of comedy that
you've been a part of but we're gonna
take a quick break so when we get back I
have a lot of questions just about you
know improv auditions I'm standing as
evil all these things we'll be right
back with more Jenna Barney I'm not too
deep guys look I know more than anyone
that it is tough to make new friends as
an adult how are you supposed to seek
out meaningful platonic relationships as
an adult when you spend most of your
time behind a desk or for me in bed chip
crumbs everywhere
laptop heating up my thighs that's where
bumblebee FF comes in and they are
sponsoring this week's episode of not
too deep so you guys probably have heard
of bumble they began as a women first
dating app edit but it now includes a
friend finding mode called bumble bee FF
you can find a kindred spirit to join
you at that yoga workshop or a fellow
90s sitcom fanatic who's down for a
Netflix marathon
no matter what your life situation
Bummel BFF helps you create the support
system that you need expand your crew
find friends who love the same things
you do and shake up your routine with
bumblebee FF to use it just download
bumble in the iOS or Android store and
switch to bumblebee FF mode within the
app super easy then fill out a profile
to let your future besties know what
you're all about
and I can say like mamrie and I've
worked with bumblebee FF before we met
people at VidCon via bumblebee FF and it
was like the coolest like least scary
way to meet like Internet friends sure
fully loved it so if you guys want to
learn more you can head to bumble
dot-com slash not too deep that's bumble
comm slash n OT t oo d EEP support for
today's show comes from third love using
millions of real womens measurements
third love designs its bras with breast
size and shape in mind for an impeccable
fit an incredible feel just answer a few
simple questions from third love's fit
finder quiz to find your perfect fit
third love offers double the number of
sizes than most brands offer cups a
through H bands up to 48 and with
lightweight memory foam cups straps that
won't slip and tagless labels you'll
want to wear these soft and a breathable
bras and underwear every day I can say
from experience as a girl like you've
heard a billion times before that only
love sports bras out of ease and comfort
that these are amazing you can wear them
under any piece of clothing and feel
totally secure feel totally comfortable
not irritated it's just it's a dream
support system third love knows that
there's a perfect bra for everyone so
right now they're offering beautiful
beautiful listeners of this podcast 15%
off your first order go to 3rd love comm
slash Grace now to find your perfect
fitting bra and get 15% off your first
purchase
that's third love comm slash grace for
15% off today back welcome back I acted
like I just woke up you put me on
we take naps during our commercial
breaks did you okay you your career from
what I've read via the internet and all
available resources is that you were
involved in like creative arts acting
and then went into interior design and
then came back to acting is that correct
yeah pretty much okay yeah what was it
that wasn't doing the job for you and
interior design that brought you back to
the acting world that's a good question
I it was kind of a convergence of
different things I was doing for a while
I wasn't doing any kind of performing
really at all except for music I was in
a band in San Francisco which was yeah
which I wish I could say it was like as
cool as people think it must have been
there is something to be said like now
if I ever have to rehearse something in
a music rehearsal space where it's just
you know you walk in and it's a bunch of
soundproof soundproof rooms and the
smell of beer like beer that has cept
into something it's like layers of years
old that is such a familiar smell really
jettisons me back to like oh yeah
drinking beer at 11:00 in the morning
and band rehearsals like not super
glamorous but yeah so I was I was really
just doing that and then it was my the
self-same people David Owen and Cole
Stratton and then our other sketch mate
who did not produce the festival with us
but with whom I'm still very very close
friends and as a filmmaker in his own
right Gabe dyani the we ended up forming
the sketch troupe and I was I was very
meek about it I do I wasn't had never
really done comedy except for whatever
comedy had gotten thrown at us in you
know doing school plays or being a
future or whatever and so I was very
nervous about it in that kind of way
that's sort of you know Oh someone else
thinks you'll be good at this and then
how disappointing for us all if you're
terrible
totally anxious and scared about it and
so and and and so that was sort of what
was happening like in my kind of
extracurricular life and then in my work
life I'd been working as in the buying
office of this wonderful kind of upscale
home furnishing store that in San
Francisco I always forget that Ethan
Ellen was a real person also Oh
historical figure I have no context I
didn't know that big in Jersey that's
how you knew you're up yeah so this was
just a sort of one-off like you know
just a great little place in in Pacific
Heights in San Francisco and and the
owner ended up deciding to close the
store and so I was sort of looking at
not having that job and not really
knowing I didn't really want to go back
to being a project manager which I had
done for an interior design firm because
that really is kind of a full-time sit
at your desk in an office job that was
hard yeah it's really hard for me and so
it was this kind of and then and then I
had just started getting some kind of
commercial work that was I mean listen
again this sounds so much more glamorous
than it is but in San Francisco there
are a lot of before the big kind of
Silicon Valley boom right there would be
a lot of companies that would want to
make their print ads or commercials with
real people which a lot of the time just
quote unquote real people yeah I know I
the time that just means we just want to
be able to use this forever and pay you
five dollars and you don't know any
better because you're not a model or an
actor right
so I had done some stuff like that
because I didn't care I mean that's
what's so great about being a real
person is you have a life that has
nothing to do with that so when someone
says can't you know here's $2,000 can we
put you on a Kashi cereal box people are
like yes you can okay that's exciting
quick question on me but do any of those
real people ads still exist out there
and Ethan I'm pretty sure if you picked
up a box of Kashi and there was a
person's face on it that's probably a
real person but I mean yours any of your
stuff right I learned some like Getty
Images stuff
sometimes they just do stock footage
yeah I'm pretty sure CENTCOM if there's
a photo of you delightfully eating salad
I will lose my goddamn mind you know
what I think there is I did I didn't
search the other day I did a search the
other day because somebody reached out
to me and said is it possible you are a
younger you with short hair is like
listening to some music as like a clip
that's available on Getty Images on on a
train and say you know they didn't it
was San Francisco but I was like oh I
think that is a thing and then my next
horrified thought was oh god if that's
true what about that Getty shoot I did
where I was wearing a business suit on
on a razor scooter
I started looking I was like googling
Everett like business woman executive
scooter footage you know like stock
footage and I couldn't find it okay well
I was really glad I no one needs to see
me on a Razors but so I guess the long
story short is those those weird things
started happening all at once where like
I was getting work to the point where
Colt the antenna and then they had
started the sketch group and then Cole
was like you're getting work without an
agent you should get an agent and so it
just kind of came all came and then we
got scouted by the Aspen Comedy Festival
came up from LA and then MADtv came up
and did a scout because San Francisco's
close and a lot of really great people
like from comedy have come out of there
like al Madrigal Janeane Garofalo Patton
Oswalt like the list goes on Logan hurt
to have across I think but
and so everything kind of happened at
once and seriously within six months of
what I had always said in the nine years
I lived in San Francisco which was I
would never move to LA like maybe six
months before I officially moved there I
was still if I never would yeah and then
within six months all that stuff kind of
happened and
thing I knew I was living in LA that's
not what some I mean you have so many
years of like comedy and sketch under
your belt what's the weirdest like
either sketch you've been a part of or
the weirdest audition I love to know
like when people that are active like
actors what's the strangest audition
thing that they've ever oh yeah you know
I I repress a lot of them so I was gonna
say I think some of them are so
humiliating that you're just like I
can't let that live in my psyche ever
again yeah I mean I think the the I
think that most people would probably
say that commercial auditions are by
their nature more humiliating there's
more like it you have to get through
something faster there's probably just
some kind of weird scenario where you
have to see something that's not really
there yeah that is yeah running up the
wall you can't believe it like how do
you and then you're like I'm be am I
being pranked every single audition I
think I'm being pranked and I had to
stop doing it so I just get so angry at
what I had to do that I wasn't even like
not even a contender for the audition I
just walk in like steam that this was
yeah I think that's I think that's a
normal healthy human response
what about sketch stuff any sketch stand
out in your mind of something that
you've been a part of or something that
you've seen yeah that's fast you're like
I can't believe this is actually
happening I think I mean the thing that
that jumped into my mind is something
that actually was something that people
really loved wasn't was one of our
sketches that we used to do that looking
back I'm like wow we really did that
which was so hard to explain it's not
that hard to explain it's so hard to
account for I think it's what I'm really
trying to say it's really easy to
explain okay but I can't explain yeah
you can yeah
knitting y-yeah okay but the framework
of what we were doing well actually was
really funny I made a lot of sense which
was Cole had written a sketch called the
12 year old boy playwright Awards and so
the idea was this person is present you
know is is and it's like the final
nominations of you know so you see a
clip of what a 12 year old boy is
interested in writing a play about so
you know the first two makes sense in
the sense that they're like you know and
now an excerpt from mr. giggle fart just
a person who giggles and farts you like
yep that's what a 12 year old boy would
write in a play and then the other one
was like I think it was called mayor
Mike tits listen it was a different time
the boobs balloons it was totally stupid
and then in a weird like right turn the
third one is a kid who did a stage
adaptation of Robert Altman's movie
shortcuts if you haven't seen shortcuts
one of the things we all used to be like
weird Robert Altman nerds and and and
loved all of his movies like into the
into the past like when your dad tells
you Pink Floyd is good it was like that
man was so like everyone was so he did
this movie called shortcuts in which
Julianne Moore there's a scene in which
Julianne Moore and maybe Mike Matthew
Modine yeah it was Matthew Modine get
into an argument thank you
and you Jack do you want to fill in what
happens because do you remember what
happens how she's not wearing any
underwear yeah she spills coffee on
herself or she's got something on her
skirt right before they're supposed to
have people over or she takes her skirt
off to kind of clean it and she's coming
while they're still having an argument
yeah and he's like wait a minute why are
you wearing any you have no underwear on
you're wearing a skirt you have no
underwear on and she's like that's not
we're not talking about that so we
recreated that scene in which I am
playing Julianne Moore and we do it
completely straight but when I take the
skirt off I have a giant like Annie wig
Merkin almost like I'm wearing a
miniskirt of hair
we would just do that super straight
like the best acting we possibly could
to try to capture the feel of that my
god I just can't believe how many times
I've done that you know I mean like if
it's one of your greatest hits you're a
trot that puppy out okay talk to me
about Stan against evil
yes what is this cuz I you guys hashtag
it a lot yes I was trying to go through
that tag and find what expect yeah did
you see a bunch of weird like I saw some
boomerang like I think you're in like a
park ranger something close enough yeah
I did play sheriff sheriff looks a lot
like a park ranger in the woods a lot so
it makes sense that it would seem that
maybe I was a this is a horror film it's
a it's a show it's just it's an IFC show
okay it is created by Dana Gould yeah is
a spectacularly funny stand up but also
a you know amazing writer wrote on The
Simpsons for many many many hours many
of the best moments in the Simpsons he
is responsible for and so it's very much
that brand of humor of just like
constant jokes very strange you know
it's not I wouldn't say it's like a
live-action cartoon but it had but it
certainly has the same absurd humor as
the Simpsons does do the Simpsons do as
people The Simpsons do as a show The
Simpsons does and so yeah so it's it's
John C McKinley plays a character named
Stan who is the former sheriff of a
small town in New Hampshire called
Willard's mill okay his wife dies he is
fired from his job as sheriff and I come
in from the big city excited to kind of
move in to the small town with my
daughter I miss recently divorced okay
and and just kind of have like a CH more
chill life than being a cop in
Boston well I don't know if any of that
that's what I was told when I don't know
that we ever much like the psychic in
the bathroom I don't think you ever see
any of that
that's just like just your inner Baxter
and so there it turns out that there is
a curse on the sheriff the role of the
sheriff and has been for a hundred years
and so every sheriff of Willard's mail
dies and it turns out that there's this
kind of weird curse on on the sheriff so
other people in the town certainly die
but it is up to evey and Stan who was
fired before he could be killed but it's
still certainly a target right he and I
have to work together to continually
fight lots of you know crazy monsters
and and we use practical effects so it's
really fun because in a room with this
giant slimy Pig monster for example
that's so cool yeah that perv is really
fun living is really fun as well it's
all blast when did you guys shoot this
we work we are third season premieres on
Halloween okay
so yeah we shoot it in Atlanta we shoot
Atlanta for New Hampshire which is like
only one of about 50 cities that Atlanta
stands in for nowadays and and and yeah
I mean it's really fun because it's like
it is the closest you know when I was
recording Cora I make the joke you know
well I'll never get to play you know
hero in real life I'm kind of a comedy
kid so I'll no one would ever ask me to
actually do anything like that and then
dana created this character and sort of
said you know you're the female Harrison
Ford so my character actually is pretty
straight on the show yeah and I get to
do a lot of like stunts
I mean on-the-job training it's not like
I went through I did but I had to go to
a firing range and you know learn how to
fire a gun which I had never done before
it's I find it terrifying it makes me
really I was just I mean it's more
adrenaline it's like a month's worth of
adrenaline yeah in an hour's time yeah
yeah but that's insane like such a cool
different muscle to flare it's really
fun it's really fun it's it's fun to
sort of make the stunt like I have a
wonderful wonderful stunt double whoo
for sure all the really hard stuff for
news Amy and then Bob Fisher who's our
stunt coordinator to make them proud of
me when they're like no this one you
might be like do you wanna try it do you
want to do this one like Amy can do it
but you'd probably be able to do this
one I get so excited like and I don't
question whether it's safe or not I was
like I trust them implicitly
so the fearlessness that I don't have in
my regular life kind of comes on for
that yeah and then it almost feels like
probably like a maternal paternal like
I'm making them proud of me that's so
sweet
okay I want to ask you about the JV Club
which is your podcast yeah and this is
where you ask people about like they're
adolescents yeah how did this you better
get ready because you know that you're
gonna please come on yeah bird story oh
that's my branch
yeah that sounds more like a body
response yeah yeah I've been doing it
for six or seven years mmm no I'm
staring down the barrel of my 300th
episode but I had to take a little
hiatus because I was out of the country
and just kind of gone for the last month
and then also was sort of looking at
shuffling over and moving into a
different network and then weirdly
before I even announced that was
happening the Nerdist podcast network
basically collapsed so moving a little
faster now I guess I actually have to
complete my preparation yeah the
universe works in weird ways we have had
our fair share of all that multiple
times over yeah I'm not too deep and
adapt yeah but what was the impetus for
this because I know you grew up Mormon
right and then you left Mormon yeah
that's a fair characterization I would
never I wouldn't say I ever believed in
anything yeah yeah I grew up Catholic I
did all the sacraments and right now cuz
your family's like guess what you're
doing but also we went back my
grandmother passed away a couple weeks
ago we went and home for her funeral and
we all went to the Catholic Church
because that's what she wanted and it
was just me and my brothers and I
literally like five minutes into the
master Switzer to my brother like this
is [ __ ] weirder than I remember this
being a little distance came back and
they're trying to smoke us out this
goddamn incense now you know what that
is I I love
I wouldn't say love but I find Catholic
ceremonies very fascinating for all the
reasons you just described because
Mormon religion I my mom had custody of
me on Sunday so I had to go to church
with her but it is so vanilla in
comparison so you know the church the
the Mormon Church's are are except for
the temples which are sort of
spectacular and of what they focus very
beautiful they are
yeah yeah but the but the actual like
regular weekly meeting houses are
purposefully more like you know what I
ain't week or what yeah I mean they're
just completely please no stained glass
there's no you know the sacrament is
like they like the teenage boys you know
sort of in stop being an altar boy or
just like a kid with the priesthood who
tears up little pieces of Wonder Bread
yeah and I would have killed for Wonder
Bread is I would be so hungry and then
but that it was so gummy like so quickly
just like your poop are kind of
participate in it you take the there's
the trays that go down the aisle and
your but but yeah so the idea of like
going and like kneeling in front of
someone who's putting like a little
beautiful waiver on your tongue and they
don't believe Mormons don't believe that
you know the in transubstantiation
that's what it's called right that
Mormons aren't like yes thank you aren't
saying ah now now I have Christ's body
and blood in my stomach which I prefer
believe that but yeah they're like and
now I have some blood and body and yeah
it's a full cannibal here yeah guys I
don't know why more nerds aren't into it
I mean
crossed into the fantasy genre I mean
that's really where it's at your best
sliver of real life cannibalism vampires
but yeah so so you went and you were
like wow because it was weird and also
like all of we did like the you know
communion and my mom like whispers my
parents are also divorced and like my
mom whispered like oh it's gonna be
weird when none of my brothers and
sisters go up and none of the kids go up
and literally thinking take communion
and like my uncle went up and was the
only one and there's like 50 of us in
this church just sitting in the pews I
was like this is our silent protest
my family's cool yeah this is what's
going on with your church right now
that's okay but so did I any play into
you starting the podcast or I mean for
me I think it was more that I felt like
I was being I felt like I was being
confronted living in LA having moved
from what I would sometimes
affectionately term the real world of
being in San Francisco and kind of
having what I called like a grown-up job
or you know whatever to going to this
place where sudden I mean I couldn't the
first when when the managers who had
coaxed me into coming down just like
just crash on someone's couch for a
couple months while I did pilot season
the whole thing it just seemed so crazy
to me like the fact that I was like get
up no more like oh what's my job today
Oh put on a push-up bra and like read
these weird lines that aren't like
that's my job and find wherever I'm
supposed to go in this giant city it was
so absurd to me that it felt like I was
sort of floating above my own life like
oh this isn't a job this isn't work what
is this yeah and then and then gradually
as you sort of become accustomed to that
then the things that kind of rise to the
surface are like hard work isn't
necessarily rewarded as you find out as
you watch peers friends of yours who you
consider to be brilliant and more
talented than people you're seeing on
television not getting work or not
having an agent and bussing tables and
all of that it just becomes like it
certainly that can be true in any work
environment where somebody gets gets to
the top for your reasons or you know but
this is like it's like
predicated on timing and luck and
happenstance and relationships and just
so much of it feels arbitrary that I was
really confronted with a lot of feelings
that I could not remember having felt
since I was like 14 or 15 years old Wow
it was a sense of like insecurity and
like that self value like evaluation on
things that shouldn't matter as much
like maybe my hair was an inch too long
maybe I was one size too big like all of
these physical things yeah there were
not a part of my life in San Francisco
at all right and I was going and sitting
in these audition rooms and some people
I would just meet girls I would meet
that I had no relationship to outside of
just consistently being called in for
the same roles yeah and some of them
would have you know their way of kind of
coping with the weirdness of it would be
to be a little frosty and maybe be
competitive yeah and then some the ones
that I gravitated towards were also
feeling what I was feeling which was
like this is so weird is this weird and
and so I really started feeling this
kind of support from fellow women who
also were like this is crazy right is
this crazy that I thought well you know
what kind of looked around in the
burgeoning Podcast world of which there
weren't that many at the time and there
weren't a lot of female hosts and then
there weren't a lot of female guests
either from my observation especially in
the comedy world or sure and so I
decided to start a podcast where it was
just I would interview women and kind of
talk about the how as an adult you are
in situations all the time where you
kind of have to ask yourself like oh I
thought I had matured past this feeling
yeah I feel like I mean you've been
doing it for six years but it's a
timeless scenario this is timeless
emotion and emotional response to things
that even more now than ever really it
feels like that's a very just applicable
kind of conversation and it's a great
way to get to know somebody I think you
know I'm not I don't want to pry into
someone's personal fears and and their
you know their moments their intimate
moments of today right but I think
usually we have a little perspective
even guess I've had who are just fresh
out of being teens there's a
little bit of distance and I think you
can kind of look at it with like a sort
of fond perspective that and you feel
more inclined to kind of share that part
of yourself yeah and I so I think we've
gotten to know I say we as like me as a
listener of the pod care you know in the
moment a little progress I think we've
gotten a chance to meet people that have
opened up in ways that they don't
elsewhere just because I'm not asking
them I'm not prying into their love life
now but I'm we're hearing a lot about
you know their love life when they were
16 and just falling in love for the
first time and so you I so often walk
away going like oh my gosh I feel like
I've known that person forever you
because you just get this dose of who
they really are and and where they came
from you know that is so cool well okay
we're gonna schedule my oh yes we are
you requested so many times I was like
oh no grace I don't know where yet I
really want it to happen they were take
a quick break and we're gonna figure
this out so be right back with Internet
questions for Janet when we get back not
too deep this episode of not too deep is
brought to you by our good buddies at
Squarespace they are so good they've
been with us for a long time and they
want you to know that you can turn your
dream into a reality with Squarespace
they make it easier than ever to launch
your passion project whether you're
looking to start a business showcase
your work published content sell
products and more Squarespace is the
tool for you with beautiful templates
created by world-class designers and the
ability to customize just about anything
with a few clicks you can easily make a
beautiful website yourself they have a
powerful ecommerce functionality which
lets you sell anything online and
analytics help you grow your site in
real time
everything is optimized for mobile right
out of the box and there's nothing to
patch or upgrade ever buying domains is
simple and you'll get the help you need
with Squarespace is 24/7 award-winning
customer support
Squarespace empowers millions of people
from designers to lawyers artists to
gamers even restaurants and gyms to turn
great ideas into something real and I
can attest to this because as I've
always said pretty much every week now I
use Squarespace
real customer yeah and it works great
yeah you're gonna any problems no it's
awesome
I don't need that 24/7 customer support
just works really really it's really
easy humble brag but you guys can also
get in on the action by going to
squarespace.com slash grace for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch
use the offer code grace to save 10% off
your first purchase of a website or
domain that squarespace.com slash grace
offer code grace this episode not too
deep is brought to you by Poshmark
Poshmark is the easiest way to buy and
sell fashion items you download the free
Poshmark app to shop from tons of brands
across women's kids and men's you won't
believe the deals you'll find like Louie
Vuitton bags for $300 oh my gosh same
that seems nuts shipping is super fast
and easy for both the seller and buyer
and is handled all through the Poshmark
app so when you see something that you
want you simply make the seller an offer
so you can get the items at a price that
works for you ooh bargaining haggling
making connections need to clean out
your closet listing on Poshmark
is super easy you just upload pictures
of your stuff to the app set a price and
then ship to the lucky buyer no more
waiting in line at your local thrift
store just to leave empty-handed so
grace as you know I have a problem with
jacket I buy too many Jack you have a
lot of jackets I wasn't gonna say it I
have like seven leather jackets and you
know this app has been great for just
perusing and yeah you don't do a store
to store it's all in the app you can
peruse whenever you want also for me
it's the one that constantly gets rid of
like clothes because she's bored with
them I don't need to constantly take it
to Goodwill I can actually make maybe a
profit off of this you go get some of
that money back yeah also I don't have
to like peruse TJ Maxx Marshalls any of
these other situations I can literally
buy everything without human contact
which as we all know is my favorite sort
so instead of buying new things had to
Poshmark to shop from millions of
closets across America and today you can
get $5 off your first purchase when you
enter the invite code grace to your AC e
when you sign up so just download the
Poshmark app sign up and enter the code
grace for five bucks off your first
purchase
yes before we get to Internet questions
I'm gonna ask you the two questions I
ask every single guest that is on not
you deep and the first is who a live or
dead would you most like the throw cold
spaghetti at Oh God alive or dead cold
spaghetti kind of so specific maybe I
want to throw really hot spaghetti it
someone sure you can do that burn their
face throat hold spaghetti at oh boy
gosh it's really hard not to just get
into current events and I'm sure
everyone has the same answers yeah I see
I would that's like I'm but then I'm
sure all people also are like cold
spaghetti is too good from that's like
food that someone should be yeah you
know what I want to throw cold spaghetti
at somebody who really likes cold
spaghetti I want to throw cold spaghetti
it like a dog that loves you cold
spaghetti because it would be really
funny to watch them have that think
think of that as a gift yeah I mean you
have two dogs right I do okay what are
the things they value Scott is one and
Whitley is the other guy and with Scott
and Willie I love human names on die I'm
also a big fan that's great also big fan
okay so the other question that I ask
every single guest on the podcast is to
tell us your worst pants shooting story
or close call but you can only use three
words or three small phrases or kind of
a mix of the two so writing is college
jogging front lawn gotcha gotcha gotcha
yeah mine is flannel pajamas brand new
chair like a early morning sneeze it
like it was yesterday when I was in San
Francisco and yeah like when I was about
20 Wow
yeah that is a lot of fabric I'm glad
that you had an immediate memory my only
that's the only time anything like that
is ever happened that I was like wow the
thing I remember thinking yeah if I may
because I feel that you'll be late yeah
is
like wow it's amazing how something body
temperature goes cold this likes to do
fast after it left your body I remember
yeah that just happened I might bat
yeah immediate hot to cold and also like
blood going from like blue green to red
it's always like a bizarre beautiful
magic human bodies are not yep okay
let's get into these Internet questions
awesome okay someone wants to know
because this is kind of combining
something we haven't talked about yet
but that you had a series with geek and
sundry about escape rooms is that
something that you are into just in
general okay I've never done one race I
just get I get on the list on a JV GH
list I know I get claustrophobic and
then relying on other people I feel like
you'll see the worst side of me and I
don't know that I wanted to show that
I'm hearing everything you're saying on
the inside cuz I feel the same yeah and
it's not that yeah like it's not that
you won't feels quiet yeah you will feel
frustrated by your fellow yeah I guess
yeah you have to be distracted by the
idea of like working together and
solving and figuring things out but
someone to know do you think team avatar
could make it out of an escape room oh
yeah yeah in a second and I don't think
they would have to cheat because they're
not to bend anything at all I think they
could do it just on wits alone just on
brain oh yeah I agree with you someone
to know can you tell us about your first
day in kindergarten did you cry when
your parents left
I still remember mine and I'm older than
you
okay first of all because I love you I
do my mind is a little weird because I
went to a preschool that somehow get
like somehow I learned all my
kindergarten stuff okay does that just
mean not wetting your pants like I don't
speaking of but so my first day of
kindergarten I think might have been my
last day of kindergarten and then they
put me into first grade but yeah I
remember I remember being in
for sure I cry I mean I didn't I have I
still get homesick even when I'm at home
I don't know what that feeling is but
sometimes I'll just be at a dinner table
with a bunch of people I love and this
feeling of melancholy will wash over me
that feels exactly like you're at camp
trying to fall asleep in a cabin with a
bunch of strangers for the first night
it's like it's just this homesick
feeling so I definitely had that
separation anxiety for you know any time
I had to be separated from you know and
then and then be in a new situation well
that's I think you appeased this
seemingly dressed Twitter user okay
someone to know if you could have three
foods that you can eat perpetually with
no negative ramifications what would
they be okay so you will find this out
when you do my podcast but I play a game
of mash yeah of all my podcasts mansion
apartment tract house yeah and so that I
don't know why I just interesting that's
a weird tick isn't it does that happen I
was like watching it happen going who's
that the question I ask every person
because I love that question so Oh
Twitter person who asked me that is do
they know they're doing me a solid
they're asking me a question that I love
to ask if I could have three foods that
I could eat perpetually I I have never
grown tired of peanut butter
I do love peanut butter I would say that
I would say I would say maybe just
cereal and he just said if I can have my
choice of cereals and then I'm gonna go
I think I'm gonna go old school kid
Janet because I am sure that I will
probably wouldn't choose this now but I
want to do myself a favor younger self a
favor and say peanut M&Ms okay yeah
yes I could house a bag of phenotype to
double down on peanut butter peanut
butter
what's up okay how much I love peanut
butter I love asking people this
question and Laura wants to know what do
you wish people would stop asking you oh
sure oh boy that's a good question I
don't know if I have one of those right
now
I feel like I've had them but I don't
know if I've had I think it's I'm not
tired of it but I will say that when I
do a con and someone says you know did
you like being the voice of Korra it's
like they can ask me that all day long
so I'm not tired of it in that day but
like are you gonna be like no but yeah I
feel like you can expand your question
out to ask for more detail because you
like if anybody who has ever followed
anything I've ever said ever about that
job they already know yeah yeah but
maybe they just want to hear me say in
person like shoes I want to hear the
thing I know you're gonna say which is
that it was a glorious experience and I
just have that re you know reinforcing
my voice in my brain live yeah but you
know if you want to ask me if you think
you can only ask me one question at a
con
you can skip past that really detailed
question like ask me to really dish on
something yeah do you have when you go
to cons or when you do any sort of
events or anything do you have like what
are your limitations on like personal
questions versus like professional
questions I don't I just don't even I
think that the fandom I don't know if
it's just for the shows I've been
fortunate enough to do but I never have
anyone asked me anything I wish they
wouldn't have asked I really ever have
anyone put just really never I've
literally cannot think of one time where
I've been at a con and someone has asked
something and I've been like yeah that's
private yeah I know it's great
yeah that's not that interesting me as a
person more than people I've gotten to
work with yeah which is all great
someone to know what is your rap name Oh
my rap name good one I die I would say
right now it's probably Jay verse
because that is Jay yeah it's JV ers it
is a recent nickname that Timothy
Omundson
from psych who did Fortran rookie yeah
so amazing and he vacuumed out of
nowhere like I I don't have any memory
of him calling me Jay verse but the Tim
on the show apparently calls Janet
Varney on the show shavers
he calls it he calls me that a bunch of
times right and I've already had someone
like text me and say oh I'm definitely
calling you J verse from now on yeah
knock it down
Davers TM okay so I want to know who was
your childhood crush I like everyone on
Boy Meets World and Bruce Willis but
they're saying in present tense so I
don't know if they're a child yeah those
are two if those are both present tense
that is a truth I want to say by the way
through at least three members of the
cast of Boy Meets World was at New York
Comic Con and people worse for sure they
were really cool I did used to have a
crush on Bruce Willis I wouldn't say
that it has maintained in any way shape
or form
my biggest crushes when I was younger
were and I seriously like I know this
probably like first of all I not in love
with my father
my dad's Brad he's a good friend he's a
great day he was not like a friend dad
he was like I'm in charge dad like he
would charge me a dollar if I didn't
make my bed in the morning okay like
caveat to whatever it's about the
principle people I had crushes on were
my father's age when I was and it's
because I like worshipped my dad sense
of humor and he showed me a Steve Martin
movie or he showed me a Kevin Kline
movie I was like those are the sexy guys
in the world yeah so those were two
really those both of those guys for me
when I was like maybe to like other
people were like I love Michael J Fox
totally Kevin Kline mustache there's no
what is it philia complex here all clear
apparently I don't electro electric yeah
there you go
okay so a lot of the questions I'm just
gonna kind of like put them all in one
to wrap up with everyone wants to know
about Cora and so I think the big
question is everyone wants to know like
what's the one major thing you took away
from working on legend of korra like is
there one may
your lesson or major like life no
philosophy thing that you're like that
was really cool and changed me and I
will take this with me absolutely I mean
I think the number one thing for me was
I think what worked about Korra for some
people and maybe what people some people
didn't like about core which was how
flawed she was and that was what made it
I think possible for me to have a handle
on playing her at all because I
decisions all the time that I'm later
like what was I you know I'm sure I'm
annoying in the present to people when
I'm making bad decisions and stuff so so
I think for me it was you know just them
even the most important even the most
sort of socially important people in the
world make bad decisions and have to
overcome those things and come out
stronger and just having that reinforced
on a regular basis working on that show
made me feel stronger and made me feel
and it was such an honor to play her
quite honestly I do I've had moments
where it's so dumb but I've had moments
where I've been very scared in a
situation and I have actually thought to
myself like so TARDIS yeah and and
beyond that I thought I got to play Cora
I'm not gonna be the person who backs it
down from this because I want to do that
legacy proud yeah and so I am very
thankful that I got the opportunity to
do that because I think it continues to
make me either stand up for myself or
you know
make choices like even if I get hurt
sometimes and all you want to do is be
the baby that's like you know that I've
been like Cora went through so much
worse and she just stood right back up
and went about her business what am I
just like get to the other side of this
faster and not indulge this feeling so
yeah it's big life-changing stuff truly
that's huge
and I think that's something that is a
timeless philosophy a timeless kind of
mantra to keep to yourself regardless of
whether you're 12 or if you're 60 that
you know no matter what life's not easy
all the time but dwelling on things is
wasting your time versus like figuring
it out and that knowing that you're
capable enough to figure something out
absolutely I think that's awesome
and I think that obviously that
resonates with the audience that's been
built in the Janet Varney kind of brand
how school of comedy wonderfulness we've
reached the end of the podcast but
before you go we give everyone a little
token of our appreciation it's a
personalized fortune cookie just for you
wait a minute wait yes seriously but
Mike is it usually a fortune cookie
uh-huh that's amazing because my shows
fortune cookie I know well you can open
this up and just saw this moment six
years ago when I walked out of that fake
psychic well you know we it's yeah we'll
see you got to read the fortune I guess
to find out my god I want to apologize
I'm not gonna eat the cookie because I
would [ __ ] my pants I would throw up
because I'm allergic to flowers so
[Applause]
scared that I didn't have a future oh
yeah like to me prank it's here it's
here guys it's here okay so I read it
out loud
sure great all right here we go
this yeah this seems oddly inception II
considering your new IFC Series Fortran
rookie we're feeling a lot of pressure
Oh God we're gonna puke BRB that was
very cool to realize the connection
there thank you so much for being here
this is for having you of course this
was super fun where can people find you
and everything that you are doing if
they don't already know you can go to my
website is Janet Varney comm I'm on
twitter at Janet Varney I'm on Instagram
of a JV Club
those are good spots the JV Club podcast
is is there's a JV Club org and then I
think it's you can still find the feed
if you just draw on you know stitcher or
iTunes or whatever so the podcast is
still very much out there and available
in fortune cookie and all of it and look
for my upcoming episode on the JV club I
cannot wait yeah thank you again so much
it was so much fun those great questions
from Twitter guys awesome you guys were
great and we'll see you next time on
another episode of not too deep good bye
I feel we went deep it happens now I'm
33 I'm allowed yeah deep deep deep this
episode of not too deep is brought to
you by 3rd love 3rd love is passionate
about the perfect fit and they believe
it's time for your bra to fit you and
not the other way around their
collections are designed by women for
women so you will love the way you feel
under each and every look and now they
offer over 70 sizes and more than a
dozen styles so you'll find the perfect
bra for every moment and every outfit
and get 15% off your first purchase by
going to 3rd love.com slash grace today
not too deep is a production of grace
helbig incorporated a producer and
directed by Jack ferry producer and
editor
Melissa de mons writing by Diane Kang
post production sound by Chris Henry and
an extra special thanks to Flula for the
theme music
[Music]